okay here we are on CNN wow I'm still so
excited about this and uh there are
panels tonight we had Academy
award-winning actor Christoph Waltz was
on this
snbc host Ari melber and ABC News okay
um first of all you just said to me when
you sat down I mean the last piece I was
doing was about people in Show Business
who hate each other have you been on
sets like that where well of course
[Laughter]
right I've been in sandboxes when I was
five right playing with kids that I
hated it was about playing together not
about hating someone but my point was
you know you can hate each other and
still make something great and they've
made many movies like that and
government should do it too okay uh well
speaking of movies what does the panel
think of the climate activists who glued
themselves to the red carpet at the
Berlin Film Festival have you been to
the Berlin Film Festival not when
someone was glued to the road
yeah
are these stunts effective or just an
annoying disruption
I
better that than throwing soup at
Priceless works of art I'll take the
glue on the red carpet nobody cares was
it was it natural glue
vegan
it's about sniffing glue
okay uh YouTube Star Mr Beast is
receiving backlash for are you familiar
with Mr Beast
everyone familiar I'm not okay no
more popular he is very big I have heard
of Mr Beast I've never been to Cracker
Barrel but I've heard of Mr deuce
it's been receiving practice for funding
cataract surgery oh I did read this
story for a thousand people he funded
yeah a thousand people needed cataract
surgery and this guy's making a fortune
as a YouTube Star I mean how can you not
if you can make money and do good for
other people isn't okay I don't know
what that question is but you got a lot
of criticism you got criticism because
he used it for ratings and it's like I
think the people who got the cataract
surgery aren't too pissed about it no
that's not what the a lot of the tweets
were about and these are from some
somebody in the Washington Post said
this somebody I think at BuzzFeed said
this they were criticizing him because
their point is that
um you should not try to correct
yourself if you're blind or deaf or
something that's like ableism like it's
not it's not worse
to be blind it's just different and I
would say if that was me please help me
yes
I
he's also work
[Applause]
s
but really that I mean that's does the
same thing go for literacy ah
great question
um
Nikki Haley has called for politicians
over 75 years old to oh yes to be
required to take a mental health
competency test
I wonder who that's aimed at
um both of them right I think it's Bo I
think she's trolling it allows her to
draw attention to Biden she's in
Republican primary but it's a subtle hit
on Trump they're both older politicians
they have every right to run people the
competency test is a really long
campaign and people will assess how they
seem but shouldn't we do that for
everybody why just over 75 because
I mean
[Laughter]
[Applause]
House of Representatives right well I
mean there's only one age requirement
the Constitution has a minimum age and
that was because they were so worried
about people passing things on to their
famous Sons at the time uh there's no
maximum age but we have that for pilots
and other things but again I think it's
hard if you've covered these things you
know how it is it's hard to run for
president if you're going to see how
they do and then you're going to decide
at the debates and other forums whether
they seem like they got it well and as
Don Lemon told us on CNN women actually
can't run for president because he's
this really tight window between 35 and
40.
but
it presupposes that's the only way you
can be mentally incompetent I mean I
would take a guy who's 90 and forgets a
few things but he's seen a lot in his
life and has the experience and there's
been of course if you're if you're if
you have you know Alzheimer's and you're
not there you don't remember who your
wife is obviously that's a different
story but as opposed to somebody who's
40 and doesn't have a lot of experience
and yeah yeah I think you're right is
what's funny is I think ageism is real
we see it in a lot of Industries oh and
we see it on a sexist basis as well as I
think you mentioned uh which is fair I
just think that what's funny is the one
place that you see less ageism in our
public life would be politics when you
look at Pelosi yeah McConnell yes the
current president the last president
who's running for reelection so while I
do think it's a problem I think we
should be less ageist we were talking
about civil rights earlier that's one of
the things people discriminate on having
said that for whatever reason incumbency
Fame other things donor class and the
voters are voters the voters keep going
back to the some of the choices that are
that are upper in the age back there's a
movement in Europe going on right now
but I started by an older gentleman who
had to deal with this bank and the
movement's called I'm old not stupid
I subscribe to that what was he dealing
with his with his bank because of the oh
I see the the bank had changed some
online you know and he said but this
can't be understood and then they
treated him like an idiot and he said no
no I'm old not stupid well there there
is a lot of making you try to feel like
you're stupid when you're older I mean
they purposely do things you know why do
I need to what's that thing when you
take a picture of the the QR code thank
you
I I did do it I find that for menus to
be the most annoying thing in the world
I can do it to get my car out of valet
I'm not kidding Cracker Barrel how about
what how about when you have to go to
fill something out and it says like pick
the photos with the pickup trucks and so
it's like you have to prove to this
robot that you're a human
think about it
[Applause]
um new census data shows that California
New York saw a mass Exodus well Mass I
don't know uh yeah well 500 that wow of
people with their populations dropping
by around 500 000 people and it doesn't
say over is that in a year maybe it is
or the last couple of years can anything
bring cost of living down in desirable
places
Florida Tennessee no state income tax
right nice weather
and something else well is anything else
about those States is this a referendum
on the way we govern here in California
New York I mean obviously this is looks
like a blue State Red State thing I mean
a lot of it is Big offices in big cities
like I live in Brooklyn a lot of those
big Manhattan Towers haven't filled back
up with people but also that was an
urban plan built a long time ago and
maybe it's evolving I totally get it I
mean in all fairness I think you're it's
fine if people don't want to be in these
super expensive cities and go somewhere
else especially if they don't have to
commute to one of those skyscrapers that
often then fine but I think in New York
like I don't from what we could see
anecdotally
I don't think all those buildings are
going to fill back up they're not and
that's okay yeah you know I think one of
the good things that happened with the
pandemic was when time stopped we got a
chance to sort of like reassess and we
were saying to ourselves why do we need
to go to work five days and it and we
don't not from you know you probably
should work five days but maybe you
could get your work done in four days
they found when people work 80 of the
time if they get paid the same they do
the same amount of work because most
people in an eight-hour day they work
three hours
so why not and you know saved all that
commuter time I I love we come to the
office once a week now well obviously
today to do the show but other than yeah
you're welcome it was a pleasure uh but
other than that once a week and that's I
feel that's perfect we could do the rest
of it at home I don't need to see my my
lovely staff I love them but like once a
week is perfect here's the problem
and I mean that I totally agree but we
are losing something I mean I work from
home so like take this criticism for
what it's worth but like our generation
we already got mentored we already got
trained I think about like lawyers like
Law Firm partners aren't going out
anymore and those Associates aren't
learning how to do a trial God knows we
don't learn it in law school so like we
don't quite know what's going to be lost
and we have an entire generation who
doesn't have anyone actually telling
them how to do their jobs because we're
all home in our PJs yeah I think I think
both things are true
um I think both things are true like I
remember the very beginning of covert
with the with the lockdowns people were
like what the hell like I can't stay
home like I need to go out and then by
the end of code whatever was like what
the hell I can't go out to work I need
to stay home
[Applause]
well you have to go out to the set to
make a movie so you're going to be out
and we're going to go to the movies
together right
not at the same time okay thank you very
much we'll see you next week
foreign